under the Trump administration, members of
the intelligence community have been endlessly
smeared, but national security officials have
only been somewhat smeared.
And now Donald Trump's own former national
security officials along with a whole bunch
of others, have completely turned on him signing
a letter saying the Ukraine whistleblower,
which we now know are actually multiple.
As we get a second whistleblower close to
coming forward, the Ukraine whistleblower
did nothing wrong, and the Ukraine whistleblower
deserves to be protected.
And once again, we should all know this.
And once again, more people fall off of being
able to defend the absolutely indefensible
actions of Donald Trump.
This letter was signed by 90 90 former national
security officials and some of them literally
worked for Trump like James Nealon, Roberta
Jacobson, and Andrea Kendall Taylor.
It otherwise is signed by a whole bunch of
Democrats and a whole bunch of Republicans.
Now there's something interesting here.
There are two ways to interpret when Republicans
and Democrats agree about something in politics
in the United States because Democrats and
Republicans agreeing does not happen often.
And it's not by default a good thing.
I'll explain what I mean.
Very often when Democrats and Republicans
agree on something, it's an element of our
political system that reinforces the status
quo.
So for example, on lots of broad issues, Republicans
and Democrats are basically deferential to
the way that things are campaign finance for
example, in terms of actually changing the
laws around it, the military industrial complex
and funding of the Pentagon, there are exceptions
of course, mostly Democrats, but those are
areas where you see a lot of deference from
Republicans and Democrats to the status quo
and defending the old guard.
So sometimes when you see Democrats and Republicans
agreeing, it's not actually a good sign, but
this is not that.
This is both Democrats and Republicans standing
up to defend the speech of those who want
to hold government accountable.
They are standing up to protect someone who
is trying to raise an alarm about what government
is doing.
So we have to it very seriously.
And Trump has of course, completely panicked
over this and spent the morning with unhinged
tweet after tweet, including endlessly smearing
the whistleblower who of course has done nothing
wrong.
One example, tweet of the incoherence and
panic.
Trump's saying declassified information contradicts
the whistleblower Fox and friends, but why
are people surprised?
The partisan whistleblower was very wrong
on what was said on my perfect no pressure
call.
Would the Ukrainian president bring in another
whistleblower from the bench?
I'm actually realizing that Trump's pathological
lying and constant use of projection makes
it easier to figure out the truth from what
he tweets.
When Trump says it was a perfect no pressure
call with the Ukrainian president, that means
the opposite.
It was a call specifically to pressure Ukraine,
which is exactly what the whistleblower claims.
And by the way, Trump got this from Fox and
friends.
Understand that what Donald Trump has at his
fingertips are the most UpToDate analyses
and data from 17 or more agencies from intelligence
professionals.
And instead Trump is gathering information
and building his point of view from Steve
Doocy and Brian Kilmeade on Fox and friends.
If we don't fix this, we deserve what we get
as a result, and I don't say that in any kind
of threatening or demeaning manner.
It's if this does not, if people aren't paying
attention or are so skewed in how they interpret
what is taking place, that this doesn't raise
the alarm to a degree that we can remove this
guy in November of 2020 than in a sense we
deserve what we get because it's pathetic
and it would be a huge embarrassment, which
by the way, the embarrassing element I'm going
to deal with later this week in audience questions.
Let me know your thoughts.
I'm on Twitter at D Pacman.
The show is on Twitter at David Pakman show